.
SEAN HANNITY RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: 43 DAYS.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
HURRICANE IAN IS STRENGTHENING
IN THE CARIBBEAN NEARING THE
FLORIDA COAST.
THE LATEST UPDATES.
AND CRIME IN DEMOCRATIC CITIES
AND TOWNS IS GOING FROM BAD TO
WORSE.
YOU HEARD TUCKER.
THAT PHILADELPHIA STORE
RANSACKED.
WE WILL SHOW YOU THE FULL TAPE.
FOR A PENNSYLVANIA SENATE
CANDIDATE FETTERMAN, HIS ADS ARE
DISTURBING.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE EAGLES ARE SO MUCH BETTER
THAN THE EAGLES.
>> Sean: I THINK HE MEANT THE
STEELERS.
ACTOR ALEC BALDWIN IS FACING
CRIMINAL CHARGES AND AN
INDICTMENT.
FIRST TONIGHT DEMOCRATS ARE MORE
DESPERATE THAN EVER TO DISTRACT
FROM JOE BIDEN'S FAILURES AS
THEIR MID-TERM WARNING SIGNS ARE
FLASHING BRIGHTER.
AMERICANS ARE REJECTING THE
DESTRUCTIVE SOCIALIST AGENDA.
AMERICANS ARE REJECTING THEIR
RADICAL OPEN BORDERS.
THEY ARE REJECTING THEIR EXTREME
GREEN NEW DEAL AND CLIMATE
ALARMISTS.
AMERICANS ARE REJECTING THIS
DEFUND THE NO CASH BAIL.
AMERICANS ARE REJECTING THE
STUDENT LOAN BAIL OUT AND THEIR
RECKLESS SPENDING AND OUT OF
CONTROL HIGH INFLATION LUNACY.
THEY ARE REJECTING THE NEVER
ENDING OBSESSION WITH ALL THINGS
JANUARY 6TH AND DONALD TRUMP AND
THE POLITICS OF PERSONAL
DESTRUCTION.
THAT'S THE REASON WHY TONIGHT
DEMOCRATS ARE DESPERATE TO
DEMONIZE AND SLANDER ANY
REPUBLICAN AT ALL COSTS AND TRY
TO HIDE THEIR OWN EXTREMISM ON
ABORTION, BORDERS AND ENERGY.
THEY ARE IMPLODING IN TERMS OF
POPULARITY WITH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
WE WILL START TONIGHT WITH
A SIMPLE BASIC QUESTION SIMILAR
TO WHAT REAGAN ASKED IN 1984 FOR
REELECTION.
ARE YOU BETTER OFF THAN YOU WERE
4 YEARS AGO?
ARE YOU BETTER OFF NOW THAN
BEFORE JOE BIDEN TOOK OFFICE?
IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
BETTER OFF UNDER RISING
INFLATION, RISING CRIME AND
RISING GAS PRICES AND SINKING
401K'S?
CAN YOU NAME A SINGLE THING THAT
JOE BIDEN DID TO MAKE YOUR LIFE
BETTER.
IF THIS MID-TERM ELECTION IS
A REFERENDUM ON JOE BIDEN, THE
DEMOCRATS ARE DOOMED.
LISTEN TO JEN PSAKI YESTERDAY.
>> I THINK DEMOCRATS IF THE
ELECTION IS ABOUT WHO IS THE
MOST EXTREME, AS WE SAW KEVIN
MCCARTHY TOUCH ON WITH MARJORIE
TAYLOR GREEN, THEN THEY WILL
WIN.
IT'S A REFERENDUM ON THE
PRESIDENT THEY WILL LOSE AND
THEY KNOW THAT.
CRIME IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
VULNERABILITIES.
>> Sean: IF IT'S A REFERENDUM ON
THE PRESIDENT THEY WILL LOSE.
BIDEN'S FAILURES ARE THE REASON
THE DEMOCRATS ARE DOUBLING DOWN
ON LEFT WING SMEAR TACTICS AND
AGAINST CONSERVATIVES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
THAT'S ALL THEY'VE GOT.
THEY HAVE DONE NOTHING TO
IMPROVE THE LIVES OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
JUST THE OPPOSITE.
THIS SOCIALISM AND NEW GREEN
DEAL IS CRUSHING THEM.
HILLARY CLINTON COMPARING TRUMP
SUPPORTERS TO NAZI'SES.
-->> I REMEMBER AS A YOUNG
STUDENT TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
DID PEOPLE GET BASICALLY DRAWN
IN BY HITLER?
I WOULD WATCH NEWS REELS AND SEE
THIS GUY RANTING AND RAVING AND
PEOPLE SHOUTING AND RAISING
THEIR ARMS.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THESE PEOPLE?
YOU SAW THE RALLY IN OHIO THE
OTHER NIGHT.
TRUMP RANTING AND RAVING FOR
MORE THAN AN HOUR.
YOU HAVE ROWS OF YOUNG MEN WITH
THEIR ARMS RAISED.
WHAT IS GOING ON?
>> Sean: BITTER AMERICANS
CLINGING TO THEIR GODS AND GUNS,
BIBLES AND RELIGION.
THE SMELLY WALSMART -- WAL-MART
SHOPPERS VOTE FOR TRUMP.
THE DEMOCRATS CAN'T RUN ON THEIR
RECORDS.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
CLOBBERED BY THEIR POLICIES AND
INFLATION.
THE AVERAGE AMERICAN HOUSEHOLD
IS PAYING MORE PER YEAR SINCE
JOE BIDEN BECAME PRESIDENT.
DON'T BY THE DEMOCRAT ELECTION
YEAR CONVERSION ON CRIME AND
VIOLENCE.
CRIME IS GETTING WORSE.
IT WASSED JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA
HARRIS AND DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISTS
TO BLAME.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
OVER THE WEEKEND IN PHILADELPHIA
JUVENILES RANSACKED THE PLACE
AND STOLE ITEMS.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THEM?
NOTHING.
IN NEW YORK CITY WE ARE SEEING
MORE DEVASTATING EFFECTS OF
THEIR PRO-CRIMINAL PROSECUTORS.
WE ARE LEARNING THAT A MAN
ACCUSED OF RAPING HIS TEENAGE
RELATIVE GOT A SWEETHEART DEAL
FROM BRAGG AND ASSAULTED 5 MORE
PEOPLE 1 MONTH LATER.
UNDER THE DEMOCRATIC RULE, HARD
WORKING AMERICAN FAMILIES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY SEE CRIME RISEING TO
RECORD NUMBERS.
COMFORTS ARE UP AND QUALITY OF
LIFE DOWN.
-- COSTS.
THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE WON'T GIVE
A STRAIGHT ANSWER ON WHETHER
BIDEN THINKS AMERICAN CITIES ARE
SAFE.
I KNOW IT'S THEIR POLICIES
FUELLING THE CRIME SURGE IN CITY
AFTER CITY.
THE GOOD NEWS IS HOUSE
REPUBLICANS LED BY KEVIN
MCCARTHY, THEY ARE PUSHING BACK
NOT JUST WITH ATTACKING
DEMOCRATS.
THEY ARE PUTTING THEIR STATED
PROMISES AND COMMITMENTS IN
WRITING.
THEY WILL ALL SIGN IT.
OFFERING REAL SOLUTIONS TO UNDO
THE DAMAGE DONE IN 20 MONTHS BY
THE DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST PARTY.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN:
4 MAJOR CATEGORIES.
SO WHAT DOES IT MEAN?
FIXING INFLATION AND FIXING
RECKLESS SPENDING.
FIXING THE BROKEN BORDERS.
RESTORING AMERICAN ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE.
STOPPING THE FLOW OF FENTANYL
AND OPIOIDS POURING INTO OUR
COUNTRY.
BOLSTERING PARENTAL RIGHTS IN
SCHOOLS.
AND RESTORING SECURITY AND
SAFETY SO PEOPLE CAN PURSUE
HAPPINESS IN EVERY TOWN AND CITY
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THESE ARE THE ISSUES AT THE TOP
OF VOTERS MINDS.
LOOK AT PENNSYLVANIA, OHIO,
WISCONSIN AND NEVADA AND FLORIDA
AND GEORGIA.
IN 4